The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANDREW LO: In today's
lecture, I want
to continue where we
were last time in talking
about applications of the
net present value rule
to capital budgeting
and project financing.
As promised, today
what I'm going to do
is to talk specifically
about other alternatives
to net present value
that are not recommended,
but which you need
to know about simply
because they actually are used
in practice to some degree.
And you have to be an
intelligent consumer
of all of these
different ideas so
that you can pick and choose.
And actually, there
are some instances
where these other
alternatives can
shed some light on
the particular problem
and challenges at hand.
I'll try to describe
those as we go over them.
Before I do, a student
came up and asked me
about a concept called
adjusted present value.
I wanted just to
make a note of that
because, so far, we've
been talking about NPV.
But in fact, both the textbook,
as well as the best practices,
would suggest that
you use something
called adjusted present value.
Which basically
makes adjustments
for things like taxes,
project interactions,
strategic alternatives,
optionality, and so on.
I want to recommend that you
first of all, keep in mind
this notion of
adjusted present value.
That's what you'll be learning
about in 402, and in more
advanced courses on capital
budgeting and project
financing.
So for now, NPV is
the right answer,
but when you learn more about
how to make those adjustments,
you're going to
want to use them,
and then we call the particular
criterion APV instead of NPF.
Just terminology that
you should be aware of.
All right, so what I want
to do today, as I said,
is to talk about three other
approaches to capital budgeting
that various professionals
have used in the past,
and which some are used to
a great extent even today.
And they are payback period and
the discounted version of that
called discounted payback.
Second is the IRR,
Internal Rate of Return,
and the third is the
profitability index.
Each of these have its
own particular uses,
and I'm going to try to describe
them to you very briefly.
And then we're going to talk
about different applications.
The bottom line, just
to be sure that there's
no misunderstanding, NPV is
always the right thing to do.
So that's what we're
recommending for any capital
budgeting application.
However, you should
still understand
what these three other
alternatives are so
that you can speak about
them intelligently, talk
about their advantages,
and disadvantages.
All right, so let's get started.
Payback period-- oh, question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this
for [INAUDIBLE]?
I mean you speak pretty
firmly about NPV being better.
ANDREW LO: Yes.
So is it people using those
other methods are wrong,
or less intelligent, or is there
anyway to kindly describe that?
ANDREW LO: So the
question is, why are they
using these other alternatives?
Let me get to that later, OK?
I mean, one could argue that
they're less intelligent.
Not everybody is
able to get into MIT
and take this wonderful course.
So by definition,
they're less intelligent.
But no, I don't want to make
such a blanket statement.
I think that,
partly, you'll find
that these other
techniques have been
used in practice both
because of cultural inertia.
They were the first to
have come on the scene
before NOV was fully worked out.
So people are just used
to doing things the way
they're used to doing it.
People don't like
change, necessarily,
when it's particularly
forced upon them.
But the second reason is that
these other methods capture
other aspects of risk
that, in certain cases,
may actually be more important
for the particular individual
decision makers.
For example, we've
talked about a lot
of different kinds of risk.
Market risk, estimation
risk, credit risk.
But what's the most
important risk to all of you
once you start
working in your jobs?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: What?
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
Career risk.
Career risk is probably
the most important risk
from the typical perspective
of the decision maker.
And frankly, some
of these measures
that I'm about to describe
focus on career risk
more than they do on the
risk to the investor,
or the shareholder.
What I'd like you all to
focus on in doing your jobs
is to try to maximize
the value of the company
from the perspective of
the owners of the company.
You are agents of the
owners, so therefore, you
want to maximize the
value to the shareholders.
But in fact, the
way people behave
is often somewhat different.
So we'll talk about
that as we describe
each of these measures.
In fact, let's talk about
the first measure as a way
to illustrate the point
about career risk.
Payback period is a
very simple concept.
It is simply the
minimum number of years
that it requires for a
particular investment
to pay back.
So if you invest a million
dollars in a project,
and it's going to generate
some revenues, the question is,
how long is it going to take
before the project earns
a million dollars?
Namely, it pays back
the original investment.
So the definition,
here, is simple.
If you assume that
cf1 through cfk
are the cash flows
to the project,
and you invest a
certain amount of cash,
cf0, initially, then the
question is, how long a period
do you need so that the sum
of the future cash flows
exceeds the initial investment?
What's the minimum number of
periods for that to happen?
And that minimum, k, is
called the payback period.
Now, right away you
see that there's
a problem because
we're adding cash
flows in different periods.
So I hope by now, when you look
at an expression like that,
it causes you great
cognitive dissonance and pain
to look at that.
It's like adding pounds to yen.
Remember we did that the
first day of class, right?
Three pounds plus
25 yen is what?
I don't know.
So when you're adding
these cash flows,
it doesn't make sense because
you're adding different units.
But let's forget
about that for now.
Let's just look at
the equation and try
to divine what we mean from it.
For independent
projects, a criterion
that you might
construct using payback
is to accept the project
if k is less than
or equal to some pre-specified
threshold, t star.
And for mutually
exclusive projects,
where you can only take
one, pick the project
that has the smallest
payback period
subject to that
threshold t star.
That's the typical
approach to using payback.
Clearly, this is a relatively
shortsighted approach.
It doesn't take into account
scale, how much money you're
going to make from this.
It doesn't take
into account risk,
other than the risk of
not getting paid back.
So it's a very,
very narrow focus
in terms of what it's
trying to accomplish.
Now, we can try to fix this.
And we can fix this by
using discounted payback.
So now at least, the cash
flows are in the same units.
So you can use
discounted payback,
but it still ignores the cash
flows after the payback period.
So in particular, you
can have a project
that requires cash inflow
today, that then generates
a bunch of positive
cash flows thereafter,
but then after the payback
period, in some future date,
it generates tremendously
negative cash flows.
Either because of some kind
of liabilities that it incurs,
or some other additional
investments that it
requires to keep it going.
All of that stuff is
ignored by payback.
So in particular, this
can have a negative NPV,
but you might still
want to take it
because it pays
back in a relatively
short period of time.
That's a mistake.
But you can understand
how something
like this ended up getting
put into practice, right?
Career risk.
If you're a manager
of a division,
and your job when you were hired
is to turn it around and make
it profitable, then
it's very important
that you take on projects
with short payback periods.
But that's not necessarily
in the best interests
of the company, or of the
investors, or even of yourself
if the incentives have
been properly calibrated.
In other words, if, as part
of your compensation contract,
they say, here, you get a
bunch of stock in the company.
We want you to maximize the
value of the shareholders.
Then what you ought to be
doing is maximizing NPV.
You're not supposed to be
focusing on other aspects.
But as a practical matter,
people look at this.
People want to know how
long is it going to be
before this thing pays back.
Now, I don't want to argue that
it's completely irrational.
Can anybody give me a rationale
for why payback is actually
a sensible thing to consider?
Yeah, David?
AUDIENCE: The main
thing that fueled
this, in an NPV
calculation, you're
assuming that you know
what cash flow's going
to be way out in the future.
ANDREW LO: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: And if
you have a big cash
flow way out in the
future end, there's
so little certainty your
career's attached to that--
ANDREW LO: That's right.
AUDIENCE: --you'd want to weight
effort more towards a calculus
and--
ANDREW LO: That's right.
So apart from the career
risk, which you mentioned,
but I want to downplay
that because I
want to argue that it
is possible for payback
to add value to shareholders.
Simply because there is an
implicit recognition for those
who use payback that it's
really hard to estimate
what's going to happen
in the distant future.
So if you've got a project
that pays back sooner rather
than later, that's
probably better
because there's less
certainty about what's
going to happen in the future.
Now there's a lot of if's
in that statement, right?
If really what you're
concerned about
is the growing uncertainty
of the project,
that ought to be reflected
in the discount rates.
So I'm not saying that
you should ignore it.
What I'm saying is that payback
is not necessarily the best
way of capturing it.
Although I think we could
acknowledge that it does
serve a useful
purpose in the sense
that it is focusing your
attention on the relatively
recent periods of cash flows.
But there may be better
ways of taking care
of that, if that's the issue.
A question or comment?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Liquidity?
ANDREW LO: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you have a project
that takes cash outflow up
front, and then
years and years out,
it gives you a big cash inflow.
From that time until the cash
outflow, you get nothing?
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That could even
present some problems
in finance.
ANDREW LO: That's right.
So another aspect of payback
is this liquidity issue.
In other words,
projects that pay back
in a shorter period of
time require less liquidity
over longer horizons.
However, once again I'm going to
say, if liquidity is the issue,
you ought to take that
into account explicitly,
and understand what the term
structure of your borrowing
costs are over
different periods.
If you factor that in, then
it should already be in there.
If.
AUDIENCE: Is that closer to a
discount rate or something--
ANDREW LO: That's right, it can.
It should certainly,
because we know
that there is a yield curve.
The typical yield curve
is upward sloping.
Typical I say, not always.
But the typical yield
curve is upward sloping.
What that's telling
you is that there's
a premium for borrowing longer.
So that basically gets
at your liquidity issue.
But if you have additional
concerns above and beyond that,
that should be reflected
in your calculations.
Payback is an inefficient
way of capturing that.
It's a very zero-one kind
of an approach to dealing
with that kind of an issue.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Think that people
they lose the payback when
they believe that
the cash flow is
the same all over the period.
Which really makes sense.
Like in multiple.
ANDREW LO: So you're saying
that it doesn't make sense.
AUDIENCE: It makes
sense, when the cash
flow will be the same--
ANDREW LO: If the cash,
yes, that's right.
If the cash flow is going to
be level, then it makes sense.
You're right.
AUDIENCE: Like multiple.
You have a multiple for
industry, you use it
and you have it.
ANDREW LO: That's
right, that's right.
There are conditions
under which payback
can give you sensible results.
But think about how restrictive
those conditions are.
You need to have
level cash flows,
and moreover, you have to be
comparing projects, all of whom
have level cash flows and
have comparable risks.
If they have different risks, or
different levels of cash flows,
or different liquidity,
all of those things,
cannot be captured by payback.
So I don't want to
beat up too much on it.
This is a relatively
easy target.
The point is that it
provides some information,
and you should know what it is.
Regardless of whether
you're going to use it.
You ought to be able to
have that at your fingertips
so when somebody says,
and undoubtedly somebody
will say to you, when
you're pushing a project,
they're going to say,
what's the payback period.
You need to know the answer.
It's not good enough
for you to say,
my 401 professor told me
it doesn't make sense.
You've got to basically
have an answer,
and then argue that
while payback doesn't
summarize all of
the characteristics
that we're concerned about.
Second method, the
profitability index.
Now this one is another
easy criterion to criticize,
but it's so close to NPV that
the only thing that really is
an issue is the scale factor.
So let me explain.
Profitability index is simply
the gross present value, as
opposed to net present value.
It's the gross
present value, divided
by the initial investment.
So the present value is
simply the present value
of all the cash flows, divided
by the initial investment.
So you could think of it
as a gross rate of return.
In other words, 1
plus the net rate
of return of your
investment in this project.
If the profitability
index is greater than 1,
take the project.
If it's less than 1,
don't take the project.
And if you've got a bunch of
mutually exclusive projects,
pick the one that has the
highest profitability index.
That's the approach.
Now what's wrong with this?
It's not that far off from NPV.
In fact, you could show
that with a profitability
index is greater than 1, you've
got a positive NPV project.
When the profitability
index is less than 1,
you've got a
negative NPV project.
So in terms of taking
or not taking a project,
it's actually the same as NPV.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: The thing it doesn't
tell you is how much they
usually must have [INAUDIBLE].
It can be $1 or $1 billion.
ANDREW LO: That's
right, exactly.
There's nothing that
tells you about scale.
So, if you guys give me
$1 and I give you back $2,
that's going to have a
profitability index of 2.
Which is going to look
really good relative
to an investment in
Berkshire Hathaway
20 years ago, because that
may not have given you
the same profitability index.
But Warren Buffett has
made a lot more money
than just a dollar.
So, this ignores
scale and that's
obviously something
that you can't
afford to do when you've got
mutually exclusive projects
where you're ranking them.
You don't want to pick the one
with the highest profitability
index.
What you want to do is
to pick the one that
is generating the
most value for you,
in terms of dollars and cents.
In other words, NPV.
So once again, NPV, although
is very close to this,
is actually preferred
because you're actually
getting a hard amount of dollars
and cents as the bottom line.
Any questions about
profitability index?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: A lot of time,
the money that you have
in hand investment is limited.
[INAUDIBLE] play into a role
like when you have projects.
ANDREW LO: Well, it
does play a role.
So the question is, if you
have a limited amount of money
to invest, does
that play a role?
It absolutely does
play a role, but it
plays a role that is contrary
to what the profitability
index wants to do for you.
The profitability
index is simply
telling you whether something
is a positive or negative NPV.
It's not telling
you how much NPV
you're going to get
for the amount of money
you're going to invest.
So what you need to do is
to focus on the latter.
In other words, how
much cash are you
going to be able to generate
from a particular project?
$50, or $50 million?
That really makes
a big difference.
Particularly, if what you have
is a limited amount of cash,
scale is actually an
important concept to you.
The reason that economists
and financial economists,
by extension, focus
on rates of return?
Did that ever strike
you as being rather odd?
In other words, when you
talk to business people,
very often they'll speak
in terms of dollar amounts.
Like, a startup
costs $15 million,
or the profits for last quarter
was a million and a half
dollars.
They won't talk always
in rates of return.
Whereas economists, particularly
financial economists,
they express everything
in rates of return.
I mean, that's what we've
done in this course.
We've spent most of our time
focusing on r, not on v. v
for value, r for return.
Anybody know why that is?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: We always
look about opportunity
that we miss so maybe we
can change the direction
of our money [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW LO: Well, that's true.
But why focus on return
as opposed to dollars?
I mean, if we're
thinking about changing
the direction of
our portfolio, you
might think about
investing, instead
of a hundred thousand
dollars in high tech stocks,
take that money and invest
a hundred thousand dollars
in manufacturing.
It's still about dollars
and cents, isn't it?
When you think about your
portfolio, at some point,
you've got to look at how
much money do you have,
how much money did you have,
and is the current greater
than the latter.
You want to know whether
or not you've made money.
Why the focus on
r in this course?
Yeah, Zeke?
AUDIENCE: Could be to
get rid of the units.
ANDREW LO: I know, it
is to get rid of units.
But why do we want to
get rid of the units?
AUDIENCE: Compared
to their numbers?
ANDREW LO: But wait a minute.
Why can't you compare
dollars to dollars?
I mean, you're
right that you can
compare a 3% increase
in General Motors
to a 2% decline in Microsoft.
But you could also
compare a hundred thousand
dollar increase in your
portfolio in General Motors,
versus a $50,000
loss in Microsoft.
Yeah, Courtney?
AUDIENCE: It goes back
to scale because it's
a $50,000 [INAUDIBLE]
for that company,
but it could be your
entire company's profit.
So it shows a return on
an individualized basis.
ANDREW LO: It shows the return
on an individualized basis,
and it gets rid of the scale.
That's true.
So you're able to compare the
scale for different companies,
but what's wrong with
using dollars to do that?
I mean, if you're an investor.
So from the investor's
perspective,
if you're looking at an
investment in General Electric
versus Microsoft, wouldn't
dollars make more sense?
Rather than returns?
Because you can still
compare them, right?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you're
going to invest
x amount in both companies, it
might create a greater impact
on one.
And you want to see where
your money is going to be or--
ANDREW LO: OK, you're
on the right idea.
You have the right elements,
but you haven't put it together.
It's true that
scale is the issue,
so you've got your finger
on the right concept.
But what about scale
is the issue here?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: I think you want
to develop a theory that says
[INAUDIBLE], that
basically you can tell them
what's your return in
terms of percentages
and then they can decide
I want to invest $100,
I want to invest
a million dollars.
ANDREW LO: Good.
So that's following
in Courtney's point
that we want to develop a
theory that suits all investors,
so it's not focused on scale.
But implicit in not
focusing on scale,
we're making another assumption.
What are we assuming?
Mike?
AUDIENCE: In terms of focusing
on the marginal dollar,
you should actually
take the highest return.
If someone's going to
triple that $3 investment,
you should at least put
your first $3 in that.
Give them bang for your buck.
And then go down
until you're getting
to a lower marginal return
on larger investments.
ANDREW LO: And why
should you do that?
Why should you go down
the line in that manner?
AUDIENCE: Because that will
maximize your overall return.
ANDREW LO: But wait a minute.
I thought that if we
put our money across all
of these various different
projects in proportion
to the standard portfolio
theory, the tangency portfolio,
we get the biggest
bang per unit risk.
So, are you saying we
ought to deviate from that?
What about the theory
that we developed
requires us to focus on
returns, rather than on dollars
invested.
You've all been very patient
in not bringing up this issue.
You've just taken it as given
that I'm telling you the truth
about focusing on returns.
Why not focus on the actual
dollars that you invest?
Remy.
AUDIENCE: Focusing on
return is the easiest way
to weigh it versus the risk.
ANDREW LO: That's
true, it does make
it easy to weigh it
against the risk.
But in the end, don't you care
about what your dollars at risk
are?
AUDIENCE: You can't
check out what it
is on the tangency portfolio.
ANDREW LO: Well, I could rewrite
the tangency portfolio in terms
of dollars, instead of return.
AUDIENCE: You don't
want to do that.
ANDREW LO: I don't want
to do that, you're right.
Why don't I want to do that?
Aside from the fact
that the fonts are not
going to fit on that axis.
Well you're on the right track.
All of you.
I think you sense
what I'm getting at,
but you haven't put
your finger on it.
Let me tie it all
together, and tell you
where you're getting,
because I think that we're
going to get there eventually.
The idea is that we want to
come up with a framework that
applies to all investors.
That's true.
And so, it would be
really convenient for us
to be able to use
returns and units of risk
so that whatever
dollars you have,
you can simply apply
the theory and find out
where you are on that frontier.
And just simply multiply by
the initial amount of wealth
to figure out all your
dollar investments.
Underlying that
approach is a belief.
And here's the belief.
The belief is that we can invest
however much money we want,
and get these kind of returns.
That's the key that all
of you are groping at.
Implicitly, I think
you understood this,
but you haven't articulated it.
What we're assuming,
when we put down
all these equations
in returns, is
that scale doesn't matter
in the sense that no matter
whether we're investing
a hundred dollars,
or a hundred million dollars,
or a hundred billion dollars.
We're going to get
the same returns.
And the fact of the matter
is that's just not true.
Scale absolutely does matter.
It matters because
the more money
you put into certain
kinds of investments,
the harder it will be
for those investments
to maintain the same
level of return.
Now, that has a very
different impact
among different industries and
among different investments.
For example, right
now, nanotechnology
is just beginning to take off.
And so, if you end up putting a
couple of extra billion dollars
in nanotechnology,
it's unlikely you're
going to really affect the
returns because the technology
is still emerging.
But if you take a very highly
capacity constrained strategy
and try to implement
that same idea,
you're going to have a
very hard time doing it.
If you decide that you want to
focus on middle level software
for dealing with file
server control mechanisms,
it's a relatively narrow sector
in the technology sector.
And you want to put $2 billion
of extra money in that sector
this month.
Good luck.
You'll have a very
hard time doing it.
Not to say that people
won't take the money.
I'm sure you can find people,
yeah, sure give me the money.
But they're not going to be able
to produce the returns that you
would expect from that very
narrow slice of the economy.
So all of what we've
done in this course
ignores scale from the
perspective of risk and reward,
but the one area where scale
absolutely matters is NPV.
In other words, when you're
a project manager trying
to figure out should I take
Project A, or take Project B,
scale matters.
As Dee pointed out,
in certain cases,
you don't have more money to
put into a particular project.
In other cases, you
have too much money
that is not suitable
for a certain project.
But the bottom line
in both cases is NPV.
Dollars.
Actual dollars and cents.
That's what you want to focus on
from the perspective of capital
budgeting or corporate finance.
Mike?
AUDIENCE: If the NPV
is really, really good,
and the return is good, you
should go get more capital--
ANDREW LO: That's
right, that's right.
If the NPV is really,
really good, first of all,
you're going to
take the project.
But secondly, what
you're going to do
is you're going to try to
figure how to scale the heck out
of the project and take
as much of it as you want.
Why?
Because more money is
preferred to less money.
Simple as that.
And again, anybody that violates
that, see me after class.
Be happy to help you.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you did that
it would go back to your--
ANDREW LO: Exactly, it would.
AUDIENCE: Or, it would change r.
ANDREW LO: It would change
r, that's the point.
That's why you shouldn't focus
on r from the perspective
of capital budgeting.
From an investor's
point of view,
from a point of view of you and
me, investing in the market,
we're not going to affect r.
I mean, I hate to depress
all of you, but most of you,
if you put your entire
wealth into the market,
you probably won't move
the market by a whole lot.
That's not true of
everybody, and it's not
true of all assets.
But it's certainly true
of the market as a whole.
In other words, if we put
all of our collective wealth
into the S&P 500, we're not
going to move it by a lot.
But if you're a
corporation, and you
put all of your corporate wealth
in one particular division
of the particular
company you're in,
that could have dramatic
consequences for the rate
of return for that project.
So scale matters for
capital budgeting.
It doesn't matter if you're
thinking about each of us
as a small investor.
And so what I derived for you in
the capital asset pricing model
is a derivation that
assumes each of us is small.
We're not going to affect
prices, or therefore, returns.
And so, we can take
returns as given.
In other words,
whether we're investing
$100,000, or $200,000, or
$15,000, or even a million,
the analytics that derived
are pretty reasonable
approximations.
That's very different
from evaluating
a particular investment
opportunity for a division
of a corporation.
That's not the stock market.
We use the stock market
as a guide for computing
the discount rate.
But the bottom line analysis
is how much of the investment
can be supported by what
you want to put into it.
And as long as the
NPV is looking good,
you want to keep doing it.
And to Remy's point, the
more you do it, most likely,
the less NPV will
come out, eventually.
And you're going
to drive the thing
into the ground in
the sense that you're
going to keep doing it until
it stops being profitable.
That's only human,
it's only natural,
it's only good business to
drive it into the ground.
Which is, by the way, what we
did in the subprime mortgage
market, right?
That's why we're in the
current crisis we're in.
We basically drove that business
into the ground and then some.
But it's a natural phenomenon
of business practice
to constantly be coming
up with new ideas.
The ones that work
well, we're going
to keep on implementing them.
We give them more
capital until they
start declining in
their rates of return,
then we take capital away.
For the next year or so, we're
going to be taking capital away
from the real estate markets.
Any questions about scale?
That was a bit of a digression,
but a useful one, in the sense
that NPV is the right
thing to do because it
doesn't ignore scale.
Whereas, for the small
investor, ignoring scale
makes perfect sense.
Because then we are able
to derive a theory that
applies to most everybody.
By the way, that theory
doesn't apply to some
of the largest investors today.
For example, certain
sovereign wealth funds,
certain public
pension funds, they
can't invest according to the
basics of portfolio theory.
Because when they
put money to work,
they're looking to put a
couple of billion dollars
to work in a single investment.
It's not worth their
time to try to figure out
how to allocate $5 million here,
$10 million here, $20 million
there.
There's not enough
hours in the day
when they're managing
a $250 billion
portfolio to be able to do that.
And so, when you're a
large, large investor,
the theory that we developed
here in this class,
it doesn't apply.
You need to take 15
433 to understand
how to deal with the issue of
price impact and large scale
investments.
Fortunately, or
unfortunately, that
won't be a problem
for most of us,
so you have to
keep that in mind.
For most of us, the
theory of investments
that we developed in this
class is perfectly appropriate.
Except when we're
talking about NPV.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because
of this lecture,
will there be any
indices or variables
that we can use to determine
the part of the initial returns
for those sort of cash flows?
ANDREW LO: In this
particular context, no.
You're going to learn about
that in 402, as well as in 434,
and some of the more advanced
courses on capital budgeting.
On how to scale an investment.
But the basic
principle, you, I think,
already know because you've
taken microeconomics.
The basic principle
of how much to invest
is not to invest until
you start losing money.
That's actually typically
how it's done in practice.
That's not necessarily the
best way of approaching it.
According to an economist,
the best way to invest
is until the point at which the
marginal benefits is actually
equal to the marginal
cost of the investment.
So when you're trying
to maximize profits,
you're asking how much
money should I invest
in a particular division.
You ought to keep
investing until the point
where the marginal benefit is
equated to the marginal cost.
In other words, where the
profit maximizing point is,
is where the marginal revenue
is equated to the marginal cost
of investment.
That's true for any
kind of an investment.
The point is to be able to
measure those things accurately
enough to find that point.
We don't do that in this
course because, again, we're
assuming that you're
relatively small relative
to the grand scheme of
the investment universe.
But as you get bigger, you need
to develop other techniques
to be able to deal with that.
And one is this marginal
benefit, marginal cost
approximation.
Other questions?
So that's the
profitability index.
I just give you a
couple of examples,
so you can take a look
at them at your leisure.
It's pretty straightforward.
All right.
Now, let me talk about the last,
and probably most important,
alternative to NPV.
This is something
that's actually
used in practice
pretty commonly,
and there are
certain areas where
it's used almost exclusively.
So it's a very
important idea that I
want to go over in detail.
The idea behind the
IRR looks simple enough
on the surface of it.
And those of you who
remember back to the lectures
that we did on bond
mathematics, you'll
recognize the IRR as
nothing more than the yield
to maturity of a bond.
So if you pretend that this
is like a bond, where i sub 0
is the market price of the
bond, and the cf1 to cft
are the coupons and principle
payment of the bond,
then the internal rate of return
is nothing more than the yield
to maturity of that bond.
That's mathematically,
formally what it is.
But it's got a different
interpretation here.
The interpretation is that i
sub 0 is the amount of money
you're paying for this project.
And cf1 through cft are
the cash flows you're
getting from the project.
And the IRR is that yield,
or that rate of return,
such that it makes the
project break-even.
In other words, the present
value of the future cash flows
is actually equal to
the amount of investment
that you put into it at
that IRR rate of return.
Any questions about
that definition?
Now implicit in
that definition are
a couple of hidden assumptions
that makes this work.
One assumption is that
the only investment
that you're going to make
in the project is upfront.
You're going to pay i
sub 0, and you're not
going to pay anything
more for that project.
It requires no more cash
inflows from you, the investor.
The second assumption,
which I guess
is sort of the
same as the first,
is that all the cash
flows are non-negative.
They're either 0 or positive.
You don't have any future
negative cash flows.
So once you invest in
your certain amount
today, then
thereafter, you simply
collect money from the project
that comes in over t periods.
If those two assumptions
are satisfied,
then this may be a
reasonable approach.
So just to be explicit,
the way that IRR is used
is for independent projects.
Accept a project if the IRR's
greater than some hurdle rate,
some IRR star.
You can think of that
as your internal,
or your required rate of return.
So as long as the break-even
IRR is equal to, or greater
than that threshold,
then you're OK.
Second, if you've got
mutually exclusive projects,
then you pick the one
that has the highest IRR.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
You could have
an outflow in the first
year, and you could
have an increase [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: I'll
show you in a minute
why you need that assumption,
those two assumptions.
In fact, when
people use IRR, they
don't bother with
any assumptions.
They just compute it.
So the assumption is to give
them the benefit of the doubt.
I want to come up with
conditions under which it might
actually make sense to use this,
and those are the conditions.
But for now, let's forget
about all conditions.
And let me tell you what
the problems are with IRR.
There are certain
situations where using IRR
will lead to the same decisions
as NPV, and there they are.
There's only one cash outflow,
which occurs at time 0.
There's only one project
under consideration,
so you have multiple projects
that you're comparing.
Third, the opportunity
cost of capital
is the same for all periods.
And the threshold
rate that you use
is set equal to the
opportunity cost of capital.
Now, the reason that
you need all of these.
I'm going to show you by
way of counterexamples.
But let me just tell
you right now, up front,
what the shortcomings
are of IRR.
Why you might want to think
twice before using it.
One is that in certain
cases, the IRR may not exist.
And in other cases, you
may have multiple IRRs.
I'm going to show
you in a minute.
Second, you're going to get
incorrect rankings for IRRs
where you're looking at
loans, loans meaning you've
got a negative cash
flow starting today,
and then positive
cash flows tomorrow--
Excuse me.
You have a positive
cash inflow today,
and negative cash going out
tomorrow and the day after.
Like a mortgage.
A mortgage, you
get money up front,
and you're paying
money out later on.
If you do that,
then you've actually
got to flip around the ranking
and take projects or loans
with smaller IRRs,
not higher IRRs.
And finally, it
also ignores scale
because it's a rate of return.
It doesn't look at
dollars and cents.
Zeke?
AUDIENCE: I have no
professional experience
but there's something
that simply bothers me.
You told that for, example,
that this model doesn't
work if you have
negative cash flows
and that people can make
mistakes and use negative cash
flows in real life.
How does this happen?
Don't people have--
in this Excel sheet,
it's a simple calculation.
How is this allowed
in professional--
ANDREW LO: Hold on for one
second, let me show you.
I'm going to show
you by example.
It's not as easy as you think.
Let me give you some examples
for incorrect rankings.
This is one example where,
as I said, with a loan
you want to pick the project
that's got a lower IRR, not
a higher IRR.
So that's one issue.
But let me give you an idea
of the nonexistence of an IRR.
Project one has two
negative cash flows.
One in the first period, and
another one in period two.
Project two has only
one negative cash flow,
but it happens in period
one, not in period zero
or in period two.
Both of these projects are
not particularly weird.
I know it's true that they don't
have negative cash flows on day
one and positive thereafter.
But I don't think you
would look at these
and say that, gee this
is really pathological,
or perverse, in any way.
It's just a different
way of structuring
your particular financing,
or your cash flows.
It turns out that in
both of these cases,
the IRR doesn't actually exist.
Now by exist, what do I mean?
Let's go back and look at
exactly how to compute IRR.
To compute an IRR, you
have to find a number that
satisfies this equation.
And so with k period
IRR calculation,
we've got k cash
flows over k years.
What, in the end, are
you trying to solve?
What kind of an equation?
Nobody on high
school math teams?
Andy?
AUDIENCE: kth order polynomial.
ANDREW LO: Yeah, a
kth order polynomial.
You all know what
that is, I hope.
Right?
Second order
polynomial's a quadratic.
ax squared plus bx
plus c equals 0.
A third order polynomial
has a cubed term, and so on.
A kth order polynomial
has powers of IRR
that are up to order k.
Anybody tell me how
many solutions there
are of a kth order polynomial?
AUDIENCE: k [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Up to k solutions.
Do you always have solutions?
AUDIENCE: No.
k is obvious.
ANDREW LO: We're getting
some different theories now.
So some says yes, some says
no, some says where k is odd.
By odd I presume
you mean not even,
as opposed to weird, right?
it actually turns
out that you can
construct a solution for every
single kth order polynomial.
But that's if you
change the definition
of what you mean by a solution.
Right, exactly.
If you introduce a
new set of numbers
called complex number,
by that I mean numbers
where the square root of
negative 1 makes sense.
If you will extend
the number system
to include these weird things
called complex numbers,
then it turns out
that all polynomials,
all kth order polynomials
have exactly k solutions.
How nice.
The problem is that
these solutions
can involve complex numbers.
And as far as we
know, complex numbers
don't have any
ready interpretation
in terms of interest and money.
So in other words, the only
solutions that matter for you
and me, for practical
purposes, is
what are called real solutions.
And in particular, not only
do they have to be real,
but it would sort of be nice
if they were positive numbers.
Because interest rates, again,
although they can be negative,
it's kind of hard to
imagine what that implies
over long periods of time.
So when I say that
a solution doesn't
exist for these two
cases, I don't mean
that they don't exist, exist.
Of course they exist,
they have to exist.
The problem is that
the solutions-- these
are two period cash flows.
So we're talking
about quadratics.
We all know the solution to
the quadratic equation of ax
squared plus bx plus c equals 0.
What's the solution?
Anyway tell me quickly?
Negative b plus or minus
the square root of b
squared minus 4ac over 2a.
Remember that?
It turns out that you don't get
real solutions all the time.
Meaning that, in certain
cases, that formula
will produce solutions that have
the square root of negative 1
in there.
And that makes no sense from
an economic perspective.
It just so happens that
in these two cases,
you should go home and try it,
and you'll see for yourself.
When you come up with
the two solutions that
exist for both of these cases,
they're complex numbers.
So I challenge you to tell
me what the right investment
decision is by looking
at those complex numbers.
It can't be done.
Which means that IRR
doesn't always work.
And here are two relatively
reasonable examples
that nobody should be
expected to look at and say,
ha, of course.
You can't use IRR here.
These are real life examples.
And by the way, this
is just two periods.
If I had five periods, and I had
some positives, some negatives,
it gets even more complicated.
So even within a
spreadsheet, where
you can see the positives
and the negatives,
and you can compute IRR--
you can do this in Excel.
And you should do that.
You'll get these weird
symbols that come up,
that will start
spitting up blood
and say that it
can't handle this.
Unfortunately, if
you did it MATLAB,
which I know a number
of you are likely to do,
you will get an answer.
MATLAB has no problem
with complex numbers.
So that's one problem.
Let me illustrate to you
though, where the problem comes
with multiplicity of solutions.
So this is a graph
of the polynomial.
In this case, the
third order polynomial.
And so what I'm doing
is I'm calculating
the NPV of project
1 and of project 2
as a function of the
underlying interest rate.
And an IRR corresponds
to a situation
where the NPV is equal to
0, the break-even point.
What you'll notice
is that the 0's
are where this curve intersects
the y-axis, or the x-axis,
sorry.
And so with the first
project, you actually
get a unique solution.
It only crosses the x-axis once.
So you get a unique,
real solution.
But if you take a
look at project 2,
project 2 crosses the x-axis
once, twice, three times.
You get three solutions.
They're all real, by the way.
You get three, real solutions.
Which one would you like?
Take your pick.
You pick the biggest one?
Or the smallest one?
Or maybe average
them, or do something?
I don't know.
The problem is that with IRR,
If the pattern of cash flows
is anything but
strictly positive,
you get weird results.
Now, I told you before that
IRR is used almost exclusively
in one particular sector,
one particular segment,
of the financial industry.
Anybody know what that is?
AUDIENCE: Bonds?
ANDREW LO: Bond?
Well, that would be a
good answer, you're right.
Yield to maturity is
what IRR is in bonds.
That wasn't what I
was thinking about,
but you're absolutely right.
IRR, in fact, is used
all the time in bonds
because you quote
yield to maturity.
And it's not surprising
because with bonds, you only
have positive cash
flows, and you only
have an initial payment upfront,
which is the price of the bond.
So all of the criteria
that I required in order
to make IRR equivalent
to NPV holds for bonds.
But I'm thinking
about something else.
What other part of
the financial industry
uses IRR as a way of
making investments?
And not only that, but
of quoting performance.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Private equity?
ANDREW LO: Private
equity, exactly.
Private equity.
In private equity, almost
every venture capitalist
will tell you what their
IRR is of their portfolio.
And there are a couple of
reasons for this practice.
One of course, is that for
most private equity ventures,
it is all about cash up
front, and then positive cash
flows thereafter.
Unless of course, you
require additional financing
like mezzanine financing.
In which case, now
you have a hard time
using IRR for the whole thing.
You could use IRR for
the separate tranches
of investments,
and again, that's
kind of an accommodation.
It's a fix for trying to deal
with the weaknesses of IRR.
If you focus just on
the particular tranche
of an investment, you've got a
tranche of investment going in,
cash flows going out, and it
all satisfies the NPV criterion.
But the other reason
for focusing on IRR
is because, again, this
is an issue of scale.
You want to compare
two investments,
and they may require
different dollar amounts,
so you'd like to
be able to compare
their performance in some way
that doesn't include the scale.
Because you want to
be able to compare
across a bunch of
different investments
and see how each manager is
doing per unit dollar invested.
However, the bottom line
of a venture capitalist
is, I've got a billion
dollars to invest.
I have to figure out
where to put my money.
I can't afford to put my money
in smaller investments that
are not going to give
me the kind of return
that I need to have.
So in the end, a
venture capitalist
is going to have to
look at scale anyway.
But for historical
and cultural reasons,
you actually have the venture
capital community the only one
that really focuses almost
exclusively on using IRR.
And for their applications,
like the bond pricing example,
it's generally OK,
but it may not be.
And so you should
understand those conditions
under which it may not be.
So I want you to refer to
these, and if you have a moment
during your holiday
break and you're bored,
you might want to run a
few of these in Excel.
Just literally try to compute
the appropriate IRR in Excel.
And just prove to
yourself that you
can't, that you get some
weird results out of that.
Any questions about IRR?
By the way, again,
there are no formulas
other than the quadratic
for how to compute it.
So in most cases when
you want to compute IRR,
you have to use
numerical methods.
You have to basically solve a
non-linear equation for a 0.
So effectively, you
have to do this.
You have to find the
0's of these equations.
That could be a little bit
of an exercise to do that.
There are other
examples here where
I try to come up
with ways to fix IRR,
maybe by looking at
incremental cash flows,
or looking at different
ranking methods.
But the bottom line is use NPV.
Be aware of how
to compute an IRR,
but you should
understand that IRR,
in the cases where it matters,
either it agrees with NPV or it
doesn't.
And if it doesn't,
you can't use it
because it's going to create
all sorts of contradictions
and weird results.
I want to conclude this
lecture on capital budgeting
by talking about what people
actually do in practice,
and give you a little bit of
a preview about what you're
going to learn in 402 as well
as in 434 and other courses
on corporate financing
and capital budgeting.
Right now, as of
maybe five years ago
when this survey was
done, for large US firms,
believe it or not,
payback period
was probably the most popular.
It's the one that people
focused on the most.
Again, not necessarily
exclusively.
So it could well be that
people use payback period
as one criterion, but they
use many others as well.
But over 80% of the companies
surveyed use payback period.
65% use IRR, which
is quite a lot.
But again, a significant
fraction of that
is private equity.
And by the way, for
non-financial corporations that
have private equity operations
within it, for example,
General Motors has a part of
their pension fund devoted
to private equity investments.
They will use IRR as well,
because other venture
capitalists use that.
NPV is actually gaining ground.
So it's now more
popular than IRR.
If you surveyed multinationals
and US corporations
20 years ago, it would
have been flipped around.
IRR would have been way
more popular than NPV,
but that's changed a lot
just in the last 20 years.
However, when you look
at multinationals,
you see that actually,
IRR is still more popular.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
When you're dealing
with foreign companies,
they may be looking
at investments
from a VC perspective, as
opposed to from a pure net cash
flow NPV perspective.
So that's something that
you'll want to be wary of.
And by the way, that's
probably one area
where you can make real
progress in terms of an impact
through your careers.
Historical comparison,
this gives you
a little bit of a
time series of how
things have changed over time.
So back in 1959,
payback period, IRR,
was quite a bit more popular.
Over time, that's declined,
and over time, IRR
has gained more ground.
But NPV, as of 1981,
was lagging far behind.
And within the last 20 years,
we see this chart where
NPV has caught up a great deal.
A large part of
that, if you want
to know where that came
from, a large part of that
was thanks to Brealey and Myers.
The textbook that
you're using now
was probably the first major
corporate finance textbook ever
written, way back in the 1980s.
And Stu Myers and Dick
Brealey wrote the book really
because there was
nothing else that
was out there that corresponded
to these kind of modern finance
principles.
And so Stu and Dick
have a lot to do
with these numbers as of today.
Other issues that we were not
able to take on in this course,
but which you will
see in 402 and 434,
is how to deal with other
aspects of the capital
budgeting process.
For example,
competitive response.
When we think about making
investments in projects,
we are assuming
everything else as given.
This is sort of like putting
money in a stock market.
When you put your money
in the stock market,
you're assuming that the means
and the variances are given.
That your investment
has no impact
on the market as a whole.
For specific kinds of projects,
that's not true at all.
The perfect market's
assumption that we
make from the perspective of
a small investor investing
in the entire market,
those set of assumptions
don't work for you
making a decision
about whether to invest
in a new technology
in your particular industry.
Because most likely,
that new technology
will have a very significant
impact on that industry
if it's any good.
So therefore,
you're going to have
to deal with competitors and
the competitive response.
Things are going to
change because of the way
you make your investments.
So that's something you'll
have to take into account.
Capital rationing,
which means you
don't have all the
money in the world.
There's a limit to how
much money you can invest,
so now, given that there are
limits to how much money you
have, you've got to pick your
opportunities more carefully.
And some of these capital
rationing requirements
are implemented over
multi-year periods.
So for example, you
might have a three year
budget of $100 million to make
investments in new technology.
Over three years, you can
use up to $100 million.
So now, not only do
you have to think
about how to spread your money
over opportunities this year,
you've got to think
about a spread it out
over a three year period.
And you have to think about
spreading it out to projects
that you don't even
know exist right now.
So the problems, the
challenges, become much,
much more complex
as you start making
the assumptions more realistic.
You've got now, the very
basics to understand
how to do this for the
very, very simple cases.
But the more advanced
courses will, one by one,
relax these assumptions
and give you
more tools to be able to
handle more complex situations.
The examples that I
give in this slide
are looking at short
run versus the long run,
as well as dealing
with general noise.
In other words, you may
be taking in lots of data,
not all of that data
is equally meaningful.
So you need to know what to
ignore, and what to focus on.
That will be part
of those challenges.
You'll get that in
402, and more in 434.
So to summarize, we are now
done with pretty much all
of the finance
theory that we need
to value and to make decisions
on virtually any kind
of investment that's out there.
The key points for
capital budgeting
is use NPV, or in the case
of more advanced kinds
of concepts, APV.
Take all projects that are
positive NPV, and if they're
mutually exclusive, take the
one with the biggest NPV.
Consider project
interactions separately.
So consider the project
on a standalone basis,
then consider any
interaction effects
that may or may not exist.
You can evaluate them
separately, and add them
together at the end.
Use after tax cash flows
for the NPV calculations,
not accounting earnings.
And when you need discount rate,
use the capital asset pricing
model.
The capital asset pricing
model provides you
with a risk adjustment for
the required rate of return.
And be wary about risks
that change over time.
So every single year you
use your cost of capital,
make sure you can justify the
particular risk associated
with that year.
Remember the example
of drilling for oil
and how the risks
change dramatically
as you go from oil
exploration to oil production.
Those are two
different activities.
Finally, think about all the
other alternatives to NPV.
And you don't have to
be a snob about it.
Don't tell people, NPV's
the only way to go.
It's either my way
or the highway.
You recognize that there
are other elements of risk
and reward that may be
captured by payback,
by internal rate of return,
by the profitability index.
But in the end,
what you're going
to want to base your
decision on is primarily
NPV considerations,
with these other factors
thrown in as well.
I'll conclude with one
last comment about capital
budgeting, which is
something that is completely
outside the purview
of this course,
but it's not outside
the purview of your MBA.
And that is that why
I've been talking
about for the exclusion of
everything else in this course
is the economic and
financial considerations.
Obviously, when you're
engaged in trying
to get a project approved, or
making a decision on a project,
there are many
other considerations
that you should
not forget about.
Considerations like
political, social, cultural,
implementation, all sorts
of practical aspects
that you need to put together.
And so all of the other
courses that you've been taking
are designed to try to get
you to think about that.
But unfortunately,
or maybe inevitably,
in a curriculum like
the MBA, we pick apart
all of the various
aspects of a decision
and then study it
to death, and try
to come up with the very best
possible approaches for each
of those particular silos.
It's your job, ultimately,
to put all of that together.
And you will do
that, you will be
asked to do that, whether
you know it or not,
when you start working.
So what I've been
focused on exclusively
is the financial and
economic considerations.
And I believe you
now have the tools
to be able to
analyze any project,
at least to get a starting
point for an intellectually
consistent way of looking at it.
But don't for a moment think
that those are the only things
that are important.
The political, social,
cultural ramifications
are going to be
extraordinarily critical,
and only you will be
able to figure out
how to put that all together.
So hopefully in this
particular course,
you've learned something
valuable from that one aspect.
But just keep in mind,
it is only one aspect,
one perspective.
And there are others that
you will have to incorporate
into your way of thinking.
That's it for capital budgeting.
Any final questions
before we move
on to the final
lecture of this course?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I just have one
small question on IRR again.
In the examples you showed,
the cash flows in the out years
and years [INAUDIBLE]
were more, they
were the opposite direction
from the initial year cash flow,
but greater than the
[INAUDIBLE] cash flow.
Does it matter that that's
not the case that can happen?
ANDREW LO: Well, I guess
the answer is, it depends.
In other words,
what you detected
was not a universal pattern
that can be systematized
and then incorporated into IRR.
In other words, if I had
a longer period of time
to be able to play
with changes of sine
and changes of magnitude, I
can get any kind of pattern
that you want.
For example, in the
dotted line curve,
I can have this curve
flip around the other way
so that it starts
negative, goes positive,
and it goes up like that.
Just by changing the sign
patterns to something else.
If I had a quartic
term in there,
I can make it even
more complicated.
So the longer the number
of periods, the more number
of periods that I have
to play with, the more
patterns that you can create
so that it would be really
impossible to reduce
it to a systematic
set other than this
proscription here.
If these four conditions
are satisfied,
then you're OK with using
this as opposed to NPV.
But that's the only
simple case where you
can say something meaningful.
By the way, the number of
0's and the nature of the 0's
of polynomials, that turns out
to be related to a very, very,
very famous and hard unsolved
problem in mathematics known
as the Riemann zeta hypothesis.
We're not going to talk
about that in this class,
unfortunately.
It is beyond the
scope of the school.
But I just want to let you
know that there is something
inherently
extraordinarily deep about
the underlying contradictions
that get generated by IRR.
You don't have to
solve the Riemann zeta
hypothesis to understand it, but
you can get very, very complex,
very quickly by looking at
these kinds of patterns.
In fact, it would
be bad news for us
if these patterns actually
mattered for investing.
The fact is they don't.
The bottom line is NPV.
How much money
are you generating
from this investment, period.
And if you focus
on that, you're not
likely to make a
lot of mistakes.
But you should at least be aware
about these other techniques.
So that's why I went over them.
Yeah, David?
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit more
about social, political,
and cultural risks.
From the perspective of the
CFO of a company for example,
who has to make a decision on
whether and where to invest.
It makes sense that there will
be some political implications
that cannot be captured
by every model.
But if I'm a private
investor and I
invest in a company that is
listed in a stock exchange,
I would expect all these
considerations to be captured
already in the stock price.
ANDREW LO: Well, yes and no.
Let me give you
an example that is
a somewhat controversial one.
I don't really know
the answer to it,
but at least we
can talk about it
in the context of
current events.
If you take a look
at what happened
with Bear Stearns versus what
happened with Lehman Brothers.
It's kind of hard to understand
why what happened, happened.
Bear Stearns was
deemed too big to fail.
And so it was navigated to a
soft landing with JP Morgan.
Lehman on the other hand,
which in certain respects
was even bigger and
even more broadly
intertwined in our financial
system, was allowed to fail.
I don't understand that from
an economic perspective.
In fact, I'm not sure there is
an economic perspective to why
it failed.
But there may be a
political dimension.
For example, and again
this is pure speculation,
so asking me for my views
on political elements,
I'm happy to provide.
But it's like asking
Roger Federer what
he thinks about the S&P 500.
Not that I'm Roger
Federer, but it's
asking somebody who's a
professional in one area what
they think about something else.
I'm not sure it's a good idea.
But the point is
that my conjecture
is that the reason Lehman
Brothers was left to fail
was because there was so
much criticism and backlash
from the Bear Stearns event that
both Treasury and the Federal
Reserve thought that it was
politically untenable for them
to do it again.
Because if they did
it again, then they
would be expected
to do it again,
and again, and again, and again.
In which case, all the
firms would be in line
to try to get a bailout.
And they are.
However, to highlight
the complexity,
to highlight the complexity
of the political dimension,
now that Lehman did
fail and it caused
such disastrous consequences,
now maybe it's truly impossible
to let any company fail.
Because people will say, oh
you remember Lehman Brothers
and what happened there?
You better not do that again.
So I don't know the answer
to the question about what
the political landscape is going
to look like a year from now,
or even six months from now.
So I don't know
whether or not it's
significant in terms
of what will happen,
but surely in the past, politics
has played a very big role,
even for private investors.
But that actually wasn't the
politics I was talking about.
That certainly matters
a great deal now,
but the kind of politics
I was talking about
was more within a company.
So I'll give you an example.
You're a new
division manager that
was specifically hired by the
CEO to turn around a division.
And in your first
quarter on the job,
you propose a very
specific restructuring
for that division.
Chances are the CEO is
going to agree with you.
Knowing nothing about
whether the proposal
is smart, or stupid,
or good, or bad,
most likely, the CEO's
going to agree with you.
Why is that?
You know why, right?
You guys agree with me.
If you agree with me, that means
that you understand something
about the political
situation that
has nothing to do with P&L,
nothing to do with NPV, nothing
to do with cost of capital
or risk adjustment.
Somebody just hired
you to do a job
and they're going
to have to give you
the benefit of the
doubt for a little while
before they can
pull in the reins.
That's what I mean by
political considerations.
So when you're thinking
about capital budgeting,
you've got to factor in all
of these considerations.
Which is hard.
It's what makes business
both an art and a science.
You need to have both of
those elements represented.
And I just wanted
to bring that up
to remind you not to forget
about those elements.
Economists have a very bad
habit, myself included.
We think that
everything is economic.
Someone said that to a
person that owns a hammer,
everything looks like a nail.
And I agree.
As an economist,
I have these tools
that I think apply
to everything.
And there's a danger
that as an economist,
I see everything from
the economic perspective.
And it's only after
you've been hit
over the head with a bunch
of failures of your theories
that you'll begin to
realize maybe there's
something else out there
that's explaining behavior.
Which I'm going to
talk about next.
But the traditional
approach of economists
is to assume that
everybody is rational,
everybody's maximizing NPV,
the markets work efficiently.
And by the way, if
that's the case,
then your job is really easy.
What makes it hard, and I would
argue fun and challenging,
is all the other
stuff that makes
this stuff not work the way
it's supposed to all the time.
You have to know when
to use these methods
and when to use other
methods in order
to be able to advance your
particular objectives.
And ultimately, you have
to understand exactly
what kind of objectives
you want to achieve.
So that's going to
actually be the topic
of the latter part of the
next lecture, is objectives.
I've told you up until now
that the objective for most
shareholders and most corporate
managers is to maximize NPV.
That is an approximation to
a much more complex reality.
So I'm about to change
your view of that reality
over the next
lecture and a half.
Any other questions?
This concludes our lecture
on capital budgeting,
and what I want to turn
to now is the last lecture
of the course, which is
efficient markets, lecture 21.
I'm going to get started
on this just very briefly
today, because we're
almost out of time.
We've got about another
10 minutes or so.
I want to give you an
overview of where we're going
and why we're going
to do this lecture.
Typically, efficient
markets is a lecture
that is given in most corporate
finance and Introductory
finance courses at the
beginning of the course.
And the reason it's
done at the beginning
is because actually, we
need this efficient markets
hypothesis to justify
most of what I taught you
over the last 13 weeks.
Let me explain why that is.
For the longest time
now in this course,
I've kept repeating that when
we need a discount rate, when
we need a price, when we
need a value, where do we go?
To the market.
All of you, right?
And we did that.
The first day of class, I
auctioned off certain items
and we engaged in
price discovery.
That's an enormous benefit,
this wisdom of crowds
that we relied on.
And that's why at the
very beginning of most
of these finance courses, we
typically teach our students
to trust in the market.
Now I didn't do
that in this course
because I don't want
you to trust the market.
I want you to learn from
experience when to trust
the market, and when not to.
But the fact of the matter is
the theories that we rely on,
this notion of risk adjustment,
this cost of capital,
this CAPM.
All of that relies on
people being rational.
It relies on all of you
in this room wanting
to hold the tangency portfolio.
It relies on supply
equaling demand.
And unless we have that kind of
behavior, a lot of our results
go out the window.
So I want to talk
about the justification
for that assumption in
this particular lecture.
I told you that I'm
going to tie together
all the various
different loose strands
of the course in
this one lecture,
and I do mean to do that.
What I'm going to
do is first of all,
make an argument for
why it is you ought
to trust in market prices.
Why the wisdom of crowds is
very wise, most of the time.
But then I want to spend the
bulk of this lecture telling
you why it can break down.
Now, I don't think
I need to tell you
that after the last 13 weeks.
You've sort of seen
that in real time.
But I want to give you an
understanding of what happened.
And actually, I'm going
to be able to provide you
with a complete and
satisfactory theory that
makes sense of everything that
has happened over the last 13
weeks.
You may be skeptical about
that, but I promise you,
it will be true.
I have a theory, which is
not generally accepted.
So I've got to start
with that disclaimer.
This is a theory that
I'm going to tell you
that is my own pet theory,
it's not in any textbook
because it's relatively new.
And if you do a search
for it on the internet,
my name was the only name
that's going to come up.
So that's both good and bad.
You're hearing it from
the horse's mouth,
but it is a horse
that's telling you this.
I'm going to start by first
explaining to you what
efficient markets is.
I think you already know, right?
You can trust the market prices.
The market price tells
you what you need to know.
And after I make
that argument, I'm
going to then turn
around and take
the other side of the
debate, and give you
all the reasons why people are
irrational, silly, mistaken,
stupid, all of the reasons that
psychologists tell us markets
are crazy, and you should
never trust in market prices.
And then I'm going to
try to bring together
the two sides of
the debate using
some recent research from
the cognitive neurosciences.
So I'm going to actually talk
a bit about the neurophysiology
of the brain, and it turns
out that that research
is going to be directly relevant
to how we interpret what's
been going on over the last 13
weeks, over the last 130 years.
Let me start with that argument
about efficient markets.
Market efficiency says
that there's no free lunch,
there's no arbitrage, you don't
get something for nothing,
prices fully reflect all
available information,
and there's no way to make
money in the marketplace.
Active management does
not add any value.
Now, if you really believe
this, why are you here?
Why are you taking finance?
Well, it turns out that there
is a reason for taking finance
even if this is true,
which is that finance
is the language by which you
conduct discussion and analysis
in business negotiations.
But even apart from this, I
would argue that most of you
are probably
thinking you can beat
the market if you
work hard enough
and if you're smart enough.
That's not the perspective
of modern finance theory.
So remember I was telling
you the difference to Warren
Buffett and modern finance.
They do part company.
Warren Buffett
literally believes
that he can pick stocks
better than you and I can.
And what academics
would have you believe
is that nobody can pick
stocks, that it's all luck,
and what you ought
to do is simply buy
the tangency portfolio.
It's going to turn out that
both of these perspectives
are wrong, and they're
right in very specific ways,
and I'm going to show you
how to put it together.
But let me first
start by motivating
this idea of efficient markets.
Why you cannot make money, why
all information is incorporated
into market prices.
And to do that, I'm going
to tell you about a research
paper that was published in
2003 by two economists, Michael
Maloney and Herold Mulhearn,
titled the complexity
of price discovery in an
efficient market, the stock
market reaction to
the Challenger crash.
Now this is a rather
somber subject.
It has to do with an event that
occurred on January 28, 1986,
at 11:39 AM.
At that time, the
Challenger space shuttle
exploded before our very eyes.
Apparently, one of
the booster rockets
ignited and destroyed
the space shuttle.
11: 47, the space shuttle was
reported to have exploded.
It came across the news
wire 12:17, Lockheed,
which is one of the contractors
that built the shuttle,
had no comment.
12:52, Rockwell International,
another one of the vendors
that built parts for the space
shuttle, they had no comment.
This is all through
the news wire.
And over the course of
the next several months,
a presidential
commission was impaneled
to study what happened with
the space shuttle explosion.
And many of you
know, the physicist
Richard Feynman
was on that panel
and wrote a dissenting
opinion about what happened.
But the bottom line, after
all the dust settled,
was that in June of that year,
so about six months later,
there was a report
that was produced
that showed that it was an
O-ring, a piece of rubber,
around a booster rocket that
ended up becoming brittle.
And because it became
brittle in the cold weather,
there were gases that leaked
from that booster rocket,
and those gases
ignited after take off.
And so in the end, after
all of this analysis,
it was determined that
the O-ring was at fault.
And who produced this
O-ring and the rocket?
It was Morton Thiokol.
They were the culprit, or
the weak link in all of this,
according to this study.
Now, this was on June 9, 1986.
Let me show you what happened
to the stock prices of all
of the different vendors
for space shuttle parts,
right after the explosion
on January the 28th,
six months earlier.
Let me show you a graph.
There are four vendors.
Lockheed, Martin Marietta,
Rockwell, and Martin Thiokol.
And these are the tick-by-tick
price changes, all normalized
to start at $1 at the very
beginning of the sample, which
was at 11 o'clock, or 11:39,
when the shuttle exploded.
So this is where
we start, we all
start with them at a dollar.
Within minutes of the explosion,
I'm talking minutes now,
not nine months or six months.
Within minutes, we see that
the stock price that gets
hit the hardest
is Morton Thiokol.
All of them get hit.
But by 1 o'clock,
Morton Thiokol's price
is down below all the others.
And this is all normalized so
that they all start off at 1.
So it's not difference of
scale, I've rescaled them.
And moreover, at
the close of trading
on that day, the only stock
that was down significantly,
the only one, was
Morton Thiokol.
They had to stop
trading in that stock
because it was down so far.
This happened in
less than six hours.
It took the
commission six months
to come up with the
O-ring and Morton Thiokol.
Now, if you look at this,
you don't see an O-ring.
But you see Morton Thiokol.
Plain and simple,
like a sore thumb.
This is what I'm talking about.
This is the wisdom of crowds.
This is why, when you
look at market prices,
you should look at them
with a certain degree of awe
and respect.
It's because it
aggregates information
like you wouldn't believe.
It's phenomenal.
So this is what economists
like to trot out
and say, see I told you so.
This is what we're good at.
What I'm going to talk
to you about on Wednesday
is all of the other examples
of where this fails.
So this is the good news.
On Wednesday, we're going
to talk about the bad news.
OK, see you then.